freiheit überall empörte bürger freiheit
heißt vor allem freiheit verbote sind
nicht freiheit und krieg es nicht
frieden es gibt gerade eine tendenz in
unserer gesellschaft freiheit plötzlich
umzudefinieren sitzung sport zu machen
wenn man noch dafür einsteht wenn man
skeptisch gegenüber eine allgemeine
impfpflicht wenn man individuelle
mobilität auch noch wichtig findet oder
auch immer noch sensibel dafür ist wo
darf der staat meinungsäußerung
irgendwie sanktionieren dann wird einem
schnell vorgeworfen man würde ein
steinzeit liberalismus vertreten eine
vulgäre freiheit wer also ist eine
angeblich wahre freiheit wir können sehr
sachlich diskutieren in einer offenen
gesellschaft darüber wo freiheit auch
manchmal eingeschränkt werden muss zum
beispiel wegen einer pandemie aber wenn
wir vergessen was freiheit über
überhaupt ist dann wird's gefährlich und
da müssen wir aufpassen ich finde es
wahnsinnig wichtiges thema und freiheit
als thema was wir zu wenig beleuchten
allerdings finde ich gerade bei der
pandemie oder der frage auch einer
impfpflicht eine debatte beim thema
freiheit sehr spannend und darauf habe
ich selbst noch keine antwort gefunden
was bedeutet ist dass ich durch eine
entscheidung mich nicht impfen zu lassen
also ich persönlich hab mich geimpft
aber wenn ich jetzt davon ausgehen ich
würde diese entscheidung treffen stelle
ich mir die frage
wie sehr schränkt ich damit
möglicherweise die freiheit von anderen
ein also in dem moment wenn mehrere
millionen die entscheidung treffen und
sagen ich verhalte mich in dieser
pandemie anders als andere bedeutet das
und da sind wir wieder bei dem
vorherigen thema das die wirtschaft
leidet das bedeutet dass möglicherweise
kinder nicht in die schule gehen könnten
weil die zahlen nach oben gehen und es
bedeutet ja dass ich menschen
gefährdet möglicherweise durch durch
mein verhalten und das finde ich eine
total spannende debatte bei der frage
inwieweit darf ich meine eigene freiheit
soweit leben dass ich die freiheit in
von anderen gefährdet ist ganz wichtig
wobei auch wenn das in der pandemie
besonders schwierig ist dieses thema
unser grundgesetz kennt das schon immer
dass auch grundrechte miteinander
kollidieren auch die freiheiten
verschiedener menschen und dass es auch
einschränkungen möglichkeiten gibt
allerdings kennt das eben dieses
verhältnismäßigkeitsprinzip und was mir
auffällt ist dass das der zeit
lächerlich gemacht wird das ist zu
moralisch
ehrenrührigen vorwurf wird wäre was ist
ihre antwort darauf ich kite fragen wenn
die leute sagen ja zum beispiel dass wir
wahrscheinlich in manchen bereichen auch
klar 3g und 2g regeln brauchen und das
ist auch ein unterschied machen muss
wenn es einen unterschied für das risiko
macht andere zu infizieren oder das
gesundheitssystem zu überlasten ob das
aber bedeuten kann dass ich in die
zwangsweise in die körperliche
unversehrtheit erwachsener menschen
eingreife ist noch mal eine andere frage
und er will ich insofern mal was
optimistisches sagen oder denen die
behaupten man bräuchte eine moderne und
freiheitsbegriff die mütter und väter
des grundgesetzes die wand verdammt klug
1949 und die wussten schon dass es auch
zusammenleben gibt verantwortung
gegenüber anderen menschen das war da
durchaus mitgedacht und trotzdem haben
die ostergeschichte die schlussfolgerung
gezogen dass es gefährlich wird wenn man
pauschal das kollektiv über das
individuum stellt und dass man die
individuellen rechte auch die
körperliche unversehrtheit grundsätzlich
sehr akkus er doktor wie man körperlich
unversehrt erhalten wir haben ja eh
gewisse rechte und wir haben ein recht
auf körperliche unversehrtheit quasi auf
gesundheit ja sozusagen wir haben alle
ein recht auf gesundheit aber das recht
auf freiheit ist halt höher dass zwei
drittel der ärzte wenn sie
wahrscheinlich arbeitslos wenn wir uns
alle vernünftig benehmen würden wir
entscheiden uns gegen gesunde dinge wir
wir ernähren uns ungesund wir bewegen
uns zu wenig wir konsumieren dinge die
nachweislich krebs verursachen und wir
brauchen sie sehen ganz gesund aus muss
ich sagen ja dafür da drin und wir haben
im einspieler grad 130 km/h gesehen
natürlich ein unfall mit 220
gravierender als einer mit 130 trotzdem
wenn ich in der notaufnahme damals einen
patienten gekommen bekommen habe und der
eines der unfallverursacher der andere
das unfallopfer dann war es nicht an mir
zu richten wer bekommt hilfe in einer
notaufnahme geht es um die triage und
dies im krieg quasi entwickelt worden
wäre ansonsten leidet bekommt die erste
hilfe egal ob er schuld hat oder nicht
und das ist etwas was wir ein bisschen
durch da habt ihr punkt den trottel berg
macht der der geht eine ganz gute
richtung und guido westerwelle hat
übrigens mal gesagt ihr ehemaliger
parteivorsitzender freiheit stirbt
zentimeterweise und den eindruck kann
man auch eigentlich jetzt wieder
gewinnen die frage die sich stellt ist
was ist eine gesellschaft bereit auch zu
tragen an problemen die es gibt und anja
auch in dem fall dann an kosten im
übertragenen sinne aber auch im
materiellen sinne um freiheit für
möglicherweise auch eine minderheit aber
wenn du sagst es ist ein stück
zentimeterweise dass guido westerwelle
angesprochen und du kennst die fdp seit
jahrzehnten glaube ich bericht ist es ja
eigentlich verteilt jahrhunderten wie
nimmst du das dann war dass man jetzt in
der regierung gerade bei diesem thema
impfpflicht zumindest zentrale figuren
wie christian lindner sagen jetzt muss
endlich zahlen also kristall in der tat
hat zumindest die andeutung gegeben dass
er für eine impfpflicht mittlerweile ist
das relativ klar gesagt er würde dafür
laut kubicki hat zu sagen hat es nicht
gesagt und es gibt in der partei warf
kubicki stand er bei uns auch bei bild
live und hat gesagt ungefähr in der fdp
ist es ungefähr 30 40 der abgeordnete
bundestag würde er schätzen sind gegen
die allgemeine impfpflicht genau und
jetzt ist die große frage was ist dafür
ein weg gegangen wurden ich glaube da
gibt es auch durchaus eine gewisse
koalitionsdisziplin die jetzt herrscht
die vielleicht auch herrschen muss weil
man auf der anderen seite frau kann
natürlich auch viel besser sagen als ich
auch dann umgekehrt von den grünen und
mit ihm das verstehen die die partei
gewählt haben die gesagt habe ich bin
gegen eben vielleicht gut bin gegen den
kopf zerbrechen dabei das analytische
leid und ich glaube dass das ist das übt
also ich meine das ist glaube ich für
viele wählerinnen und wähler von grünen
und spd genauso da wird jetzt da werden
dinge die im wahlprogramm standen oder
auch mit denen man wahlkampf gemacht hat
die werden aufgegeben und entscheidend
wird sein wie gut kann man das am ende
verkaufen seiner eigenen wählerschaft
wie gut kann man das möglicherweise auch
kompensieren also wenn die grünen jetzt
beispielsweise ein thema kohleausstieg
die 20 30 das jahr 2030 hinbekommen
sondern 2035 können sie vielleicht sagen
aber dafür gibt es jetzt tempo 130 auf
den autobahnen das haben wir
durchgesetzt so als kompensation das
wird am ende müssen die wähler
entscheiden aber ganz klar ist da gibt
es natürlich innerhalb der regierung
dann am ende wenn man aus der opposition
kommt immer einen langen weg wo man sich
ehrlich machen muss und das fenster muss
ob mir das ist ein ganz anderer freiheit
und ich auch ein ganz wichtiges thema
wie nimmst du das war die debatte auch
bei der frage wie ja nicht von otto berg
schon gestellt hatten die kritik daran
zu sagen da durch
wenn ich sozusagen nur auf meine eigene
freiheit achte beim thema corona
riskiere ich die freiheit in vieler
millionen menschen wissen glaube ich
über 11 millionen sind um wm punkte ja
ich muss erst mal sagen ich fand frau
teuteberg worte ganz toll weil das
übrigens auch mut in dieser zeit finde
jetzt bürgerin mal eine politikerin von
der freiheit spreche zuhörer nach dem
eigentlich nirgendwo mehr darüber in der
politik geredet wird ich bin ganz klar
natürlich gegen eine impfpflicht weil
ich mich frage wenn wir also jetzt im
pflicht einführen das wird ja immer
gerne masern mit corona verglichen das
kann man aber in meinen augen nicht
vergleichen weil masern wird man geimpft
und dann muss man nicht wieder geimpft
werden coruna ist eine fortlaufende
impfung was macht der staat an als
nächstes also ich frage mich halt
wirklich wie weit machen wir dem staat
noch die tür auf dass er bald alles bei
uns bestimmt und weiß was mich so stört
paul an dieser ganzen impfpflicht
diskussion an dieser debatte immer kommt
aber wenn die ungeimpften sich nicht
impfen lassen dann müssen die kinder
wieder zu hause bleiben dann die
wirtschaft ja da kann man sich aber auch
viel bei der politik bedanken weil auch
viel nicht funktioniert hat und ich
finde zum beispiel hätte man die kinder
je so lange aus der schule raus lassen
müssen das wird sich vielleicht
irgendwann analysen zeigen gemacht haben
andere länder nicht gemacht man jetzt in
anderen ländern aber das ist auch da
müssen wir durch ruß selber sein das
kommt mir damals nicht wissen aber groß
als einen grund hier wirklich vorgehen
damit milliarde mehr das was sie heute
wo wir drin schlecht drin sind ist dass
wir brauchen viel zu lange um uns um uns
etwas neues zu gewöhnen und dann
verharren wir zu lange da dabei hat sich
frau merkel dafür schuldig sehr darauf
dinge absolut sich dann schuldigen muss
ist es hier auf meinem sich
entschuldigen muss ich schon noch ein
unterschied zwischen da und ich finde
das ist der kernpunkt zwischen der
klugen und entschlossenen panini
bekämpfung einer sich aus und nach
schleichende gewöhnung an übermaß stadie
eingriffe andererseits und genau diese
gefahr besteht gerade ich finde das kann
man übrigens auch an anderen beispielen
sehen es gibt ja so banalere beispiele
würde ich nie mit einer impfpflicht
gleichsetzen aber wenn man über so wird
er oft von vielen gebracht gurtpflicht
oder ähnliches es gab doch die
straßenverkehrsordnung und solche
regelung schon bevor jetzt einige
ankamen und verbote zur freiheit um
definiert haben damals hätte aber
niemand gesagt das ist jetzt ein
ausdruck von freiheit sondern man muss
sachlich darüber diskutieren welches
risiko habe ich wie muss ich ein paar
verkehrsregeln einziehen aber ich muss
doch ehrlich mit uns dass das eine
einschränkung von freiheit ist und wenn
ich darüber ehrlich bin kann ich darüber
diskutieren in der demokratie aber wenn
ich so tun als wäre das gar keine
einschränkung dann wird es wirklich
gefährlich die mit elf millionen
menschen man muss einmal verstehen sind
das sind nicht alles impfgegner mir
schreiben täglich leute die haben
einfach wirklich angst und wenn ich
angst habe dann treffe ich keine
vernünftigen entscheidungen oder ich bin
überzeugt von etwas und auch dann musst
dein gegenüber schon ernst nehme und ich
habe menschen behandelt das waren reichs
bürger schwerverbrecher menschen die
wirklich schweres leid zugefügt haben
naja in der notaufnahme in berlin
erleben sie das so das heißt dann ist
halt die frage wie gehe ich demgegenüber
entgegen und dann ist es in der
medizinischen sich so erst mal für die
menschen da sein und auch dem helfen und
das haben wir so ein bisschen verlernt
weil wir da mit dem finger auf leute
zeigen und ich finde da sind wir
eigentlich als gesellschaft